how's it going bros my stop welcome back
to Catherine we're on the 8th they let's
let's have a little slurp what are we
gonna think about it think about
something so to summarize in case you
knew we cheated on her a girlfriend our
girlfriend broke up with me us it turned
out our other cheating girlfriend was
the succubus it turned out our other
girlfriend wasn't actually pregnant and
now it turns out the one that was behind
all this was the guy behind the bar does
that make sense I think no but is it
awesome abso-fucking-lutely let's talk
to these so there's gonna be one final
stage I think one final night those
sneaky bastards they said there were
seven but then there was eight how does
that's a dick move
oh [ __ ] it's latest [ __ ] oh it goes
straight to nightmare huh ninth day nine
[ __ ] days it's just me isn't it oh
[ __ ] look at that look how far we climb
Bros what a [ __ ] journey this has
been
how many stages are there it don't
doesn't even say the Empire area
what can't hear I'm sorry if I'm talking
over it my brain melted in the last two
like they were so difficult I didn't
leave it like it was one point I didn't
even know if I could actually do it [ __ ]
I'm pissed for being asleep
radda radda right it can see my
underpants I bet that's why he started
all this just to see my underpants well
they're enemies here all right [ __ ] off
then
thanks for the item I do appreciate it
great chick skills that make me lose a
bunch of [ __ ] items that I really
need him hello no I didn't mean to do
that
I wasn't too bad no [ __ ]
[ __ ] me dammit I [ __ ] up
don't worry browse if there's a will
there's a way
I don't know anyone named well though
hey jokes are funny aren't they
I don't know how what the [ __ ] I'm doing
sorry I really [ __ ] that out like if
you if you start making it unnecessarily
hard for yourself you might as well quit
like it's not gonna happen
the [ __ ] happened here alright alright
well I guess that [ __ ] work - nay Oh
God go go
[ __ ] me [ __ ] is it love over loves
over I'm gonna try not to suck so much
dick just be one moment and I'll take
them all out
got all collection mache just do this
why do I make it so hard for my now keep
in that canal then I can put this and I
can make me walk over
[Music]
a coat hanger get this but now why [ __ ]
oh god what the [ __ ] what did that what
did these do yeah that doesn't make any
[ __ ] sense
I wanted a [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] that [ __ ]
up Oh God
yep I'm legally blind sorry no I didn't
see them oh hey I did it
Wow Oh genius yeah oh man that was good
that was not just like she was not just
like sheesh you don't know me you don't
know what I was thinking
oh I felt good alright so now we're at
not bad indeed a [ __ ] sake this is the
last night isn't it
[Music]
it would be kind of boring no we had
shitty episode wouldn't it what's higher
than heaven yeah son of a [ __ ] oh my
god your voice is so annoying I can't
even
first question to freedom do I not like
I'm in my underwear I'm pretty sure I'm
prepared all right let's get the it real
if I were to risk your life to get your
lover back which maybe not everything
just because you can see her again
does it be prepared though well that
hinting that the person who put me here
was quiet
why aren't you value a ting me it was
just the bartender just the bartender I
may not look but where are you guys what
are my name is Astor I watch you humans
from a world a world above what you are
satisfied with my introduction that's
too bad we'll talk further on if you're
still alive wait I think shows up if I
Sasha a strong just a bunch of awkward
metal bands
excuse me while I scratch my balls yes
you needed to know that okay oh [ __ ]
girls are [ __ ] cold ha ha
almost everyone said no damn that is
some cold [ __ ] I mean I answered the
same but that is some cold how far we go
in set a [ __ ] mouth blocks what
happens if I walk here what is that that
dude this is by this tongue iran-iraq
Matthew is proud
Matthew was proud girl there we go
[ __ ] yes amazing
[Music]
[Applause]
yay I mean I should be quicker in my
boxes right it doesn't even make sense
to say that the ones where you have to
think long and hard those are not my
favorite those are my worst
those are makes me want I just shut the
[ __ ] up again what is that okay to
freedom do you wish for a peaceful life
what a stupid [ __ ] question
no sounds boring his house in temptation
which cast you down here
lies deceit betrayal so casually Ferger
Tory just men filled with traitors I
ordered him to bring the lowest of the
low like you thank you hey don't call me
that
and all this show me your face you will
never see his face not in a thousand
years besides isn't knowing his name who
is he I wish you the best of luck
I don't need your wishes I'm not gonna
lose who is after us
I'm well confused
well confused do you like this I am
trying to cosplay unicorn it's pretty
cool pretty cool hair thank you thank
you I appreciate it appreciate your
compliments keep keep them coming
most people said yes so I was in the
minority oh this one Wow can't always go
I know everyone would say yes it's
probably [ __ ] I don't know it's boring
right
what's a peaceful life I understand
peaceful as in like a good life like
living alone on a countryside where it's
nice and quiet sounds boring as hell at
me there is no way to climb this wall
trust your instincts no are we in
different here my hair does just not
want to do it today I don't know what to
do that's it
that's fine
[Music]
I think I got it oh my god oh my god oh
my god yes you probably didn't see a lot
of that but that [ __ ] took me a while
man Jesus Christ thank you lady a lot
can't help me now thank you
there is no correct answer to this may
be astra --this god and the other guy is
devil her question to freedom
do you wish for the excitement of chaos
you know i that that's what i said in
last one yeah it's fun midway point in
heaven never [ __ ] innocence there's
nothing to do but climb I'm getting out
of here
all right no that's fine
see what other people answered no well
you're [ __ ] boring aren't you it's
like you live one life why would you
make it boring I know I don't understand
why would you live a nice happy life
doesn't make any sense seems really
boring to me all your cunning well I'm
all out of [ __ ] cunning fourth stage
[Music]
okay let me just [ __ ] power through
they [ __ ] that I'm not ready but thank
you for asking appreciate it I read the
top
I think remaining it's getting so over
the top I'm just standing like right in
the heaven and [ __ ] like I don't even
know me it's gonna be my opponent
so it sounds like he's gonna be a boss
battle now first I must praise you for
having survived this far this [ __ ]
again what do I have to tell you this
time what makes you so desperate isn't
it obvious
I'm gonna get back what I lost hmm now
let me ask what are you living for what
what's the point of asking questions at
this point in your game life isn't so
simple that I can just boil it down that
easily just who are you
what do you mean uh-huh that's the curse
there's no escaping this place without
having an answer of some sort you may be
different from the average man but that
doesn't mean I can let you go I'll hear
what you truly wish for okay
are you prepared to live the rest of
your life in the excitement you wished
for man such [ __ ] questions thank you
[Music]
this challenge just like you this man
became a legend he stopped being human
then became one of us yes he is Thomas
mutton the one awaiting you at the next
trial now that he has become one of us
we call him Dumuzi all the traps were
created by him he knows this place
through and through
making him a difficult opponent he used
to be a human I'm not gonna lose this I
wonder what his story is then
this is [ __ ] turning up epic is [ __ ]
[ __ ] look at that that's ridiculous
there we go okay that's pretty badass
[Music]
and you remember our deal right let's
get this over with already
I'll run you to Katherine Thomas money
was a little put a pattern Oh guys it's
gonna be long as [ __ ] clam
[ __ ] alone a long long I wonder what
he's gonna do
that a good old moon that's my favorite
move and the whole Wildwood we're still
playing it easy so it shouldn't be too
hard
get it I was almost a joke almost being
myself
hilarious it almost starts off pretty
straightforward the [ __ ] was that are
you
I made some blocks ice you can make my
block eyes any day you want just gotta
ask
you're just being annoying alright first
checkpoint out of like a million
fantastic it's gonna be a long one
breast I'm gonna try and go he's gonna
[ __ ] noscope me what an [ __ ] you
almost got me too
yeah mess midair
bad bad bad almost no scoped well no
scope dissing health what is he doing
now that actually helped me I don't have
you realized
crazy cuz I have such a high combo for
you yet because you're not shooting me
and you're sitting in a [ __ ] chair
like it's not shoot me shoot me better
I'm having Talent that's kind of
I'm really good at banjo I wish I wish I
was really good at that count for
something
no all right I write halfway then
amazing how the [ __ ] are we gonna get up
this though I mean did it
give me a checkpoint or I'd be climbing
[ __ ] forever don't tell me I missed
the checkpoint
my god almost [ __ ] kicked number one
in the book you keep saying that
oh god oh dude that was [ __ ] close
all right I need more blocks you're too
slow [ __ ] grandpa
oh my god I'm gonna get so [ __ ]
pissed if I have to redo this I've been
climbing so long are you [ __ ] me
don't jinx it hits you can do it live
your life be happy it's the same [ __ ]
pattern over and over there it is
please please
please we were yes now you can kill me
all you want
just kidding Mike we're gonna make it to
the top a fat fat fat birdy tap then
spin around and we're almost at the top
actually I was [ __ ] easy as [ __ ] like
I'm walking and having emanated the
company
stop doing that this might be a little
harder actually no I'll be fine no
symbolize you [ __ ] oh my god what do I
do now
oh my god disgusting oh my god okay
there's no no there oh okay
I'll take it okay I'll ride out ride
Matthew McGill on math you must have
saved me not Matthew I'm so proud
whatever you know there's no way I can
make it especially now I mean Ron is
falling in [ __ ]
this has been great I tried so hard and
got so far in the end
it didn't even matter that song this is
great this is just the just what I
wanted
yes oh the [ __ ] is this now what system
oh oh how are right all right that I was
like
curse you insect but I'm an amped what
is going on with that goal doesn't look
like home you proud of me senpai can
[Music]
that was just the first part foxy
he's pissed now
last question oh my god waiting for me
huh
you're trying to kill me this whole time
this is a sanctuary where we give those
with potential a baptism and freedom
this is a game of death where experience
and intuition are your only tools to
survive there is no right and wrong
tomorrow only comes for those with the
power to overcome the challenge yeah I
kind of already knew that this is all a
dream in my head that this is my dream
that no matter what comes my way I know
I'll be able to handle it you are both
so different from the man who first
entered here my job here is done you've
successfully endured the baptism coming
next will be the final trial of the
heavens this will be your last battle I
am always near you I have many faces
Jesus is bathed in Ishtar's love I'll
see you again in a place it's Jesus
isn't it somewhere else
keep your eyes up and go tell me twice
it's Emma's juices all on
I knew it I knew it I said it said it
many times
merkat that [ __ ] [ __ ] that is
definitely the last one isn't it Danny
damn orangutan the final stage of the
great release and it makes me sad and
it's almost over with all your might
when you reach heaven's door you will
gain I notice that it is it says six
fear and not final swear which makes him
yellow anxious how do you watch my every
move you should know Beach
[Music]
oh well you're fine
Vox employed oh oh you raised a nasty I
got this is a horror game now Cinzia
infinite confident gone do not well have
the game tells me do not die thank you
thank you so much
you really made all the difference
oh oh oh
easy The Terminator I think he's
determining it it's so disgusting [ __ ]
is up with Japanese people coming up
with disgusting [ __ ] I'm kind of stuck
now RNA
no nevermind [ __ ] yeah
Oh God we're [ __ ] close and we're not
even [ __ ] close fart noises yep
that's that's where we are right now
right now
[ __ ] that's pretty high how am I gonna
get there come check me hi can we do it
fantastic thank you so much
god damn and that destroyed me
seriously right now
thank you we we [ __ ] will do this
[ __ ] [ __ ]
I don't know how no seriously I really
don't know how
oh okay now all right
[ __ ] you then
alright alright
[Music]
come on yes your smooch hey you [ __ ] I
don't think I can do that twice so I
really [ __ ] hope I don't die oh my
god please daddy come don't get
distracted by the money just keep going
for your goal
let me go on
we're so close
oh my god oh my god oh my god say oh my
god again oh my god [ __ ] is this come on
baby come on baby where would that
Cheney even be attached oh did we do it
uh what is this no you'll never with you
don't call me a bastard please I already
did god damn it is not over shut off
you're an even bigger fool than I
thought you little wretch
you're not going to prevent me from
saving your rates by being stubborn
that's still what you think look men and
women they're more complicated than you
think you're just being selfish
alright mutton what I want doesn't
really matter I mean people's lives
aren't planned out for them there's no
road map despite what you may think we
don't need any hurting home I can't
claim to be the greatest guy in the
world or anything but I am human and I'm
free to choose how I live
you insolent little man well thank you
but I still won you made me go through
these stupid dreams night after night
from now on my life is my own and I have
a pillow
stubby cool
mine
are we meeting Jesus sent by we didn't
that must be the final level that has
that has to be the final level there's
no way in hell that that's not the final
level if that's not the final level
don't get me wrong I don't want it to
end but I don't I don't want more extra
bonus final extra extra level final all
right that we were passed at about six
levels ago
I'm just saying and I'm a unicorn
fabulous unicorn thank you thank you the
berry there's two nice to me I don't
understand we wake up Kathy okay
hey hey Katherine Katherine can I thank
you
how do we know this is not a dream in a
dream we just know are we gonna call
Katherine and see how she reacts
no we're what changed nothing changed
you were still an [ __ ] if you cheat
on your girlfriend just challenged debt
the devil and that's it oh he's there
now pretty odd request why do you want
to do this anyway you promised me you'd
get her to meet me that's all I want you
say she's just an illusion I don't buy
it
well she is an illusion in this realm
but a promise is a promise
I can't stop you from meeting with her
enough with the threats so we went with
the Catherine with a C after all this
are you kidding me
hi Ben I mean it's it's good to see you
again yeah I've never been called out
like this before you know what I am
scared
[Music]
helping him out you're the one who
wanted me and you're the one who
rejected me
remember no you asked me to meet you
here well not to talk with me yeah of
course with you look don't worry about
it I don't care that you dumped me
you well no that's not it it's not like
we still have a rum and coke
something I want something I have to
tell you I'm listening so I would then
already I've made up my mind your mind
before I was worried about my future I
thought my life was being decided for me
but meeting you I feel like I've
overcome that what are you saying you
met me and overcame what I don't know
how to say it society's all about
patience and self-sacrifice right I mean
everyone practically kills themselves to
stay safely within the herd I hate that
life
where's stray sheep means I'm going
astray myself that's why I was willing
to go through all of that nightmare
[ __ ] I made it out alive I'm not in
the herd anymore
now that I've met you I've lost all
hesitation that I had I'm totally free
now together we can both live our lives
to the fullest without chaining each
other down I see and so I've decided I
want to live with you me wait what are
you saying
living with me means I can quit being
human if that's what it takes
I've made up my mind don't you believe
me
Vincent oh my god oh my no we got I want
you let's get married
marry me we can do it all right good I'm
glad that you understand all I want is
for you to be with me you can do
whatever you want okay whenever I want
you know I'm not human right that could
present problems such as lots of them
actually besides it's not like I can
stay here with you the thing is Vince
the whole kid thing would have to be off
the table and I mean everything I did to
you I might do to other guys
oh yeah why don't we just take it one
day at a time one day at a time and
you're okay with that
I'm sure we'll manage somehow
I heard you human what at all damnation
you prattling on about a one day at a
time with honor absurdity a mere human
dares ask to Wed the daughter of the
plenipotentiary of the netherworld
not at my house you're his daughter this
guy's father
you got a promise let's go home you
promised you play video games with me
tonight okay let's just cut to the chase
then I need to know okay no more games
now Catherine what do you think of me
honestly what in human terms I guess I
liked you that settles it then
marry me Catherine
[Music]
all right well what the [ __ ] was I care
about it's you again perfect escape from
the terrifying you let Vincent out with
your exceptional skills even
Astaroth the mastermind behind the
nightmares was amazed thank you the
central conflict that this games
masterful creators placed at its cause
Wow are they shoving it in our face said
that what it was about
interesting huh the stairway Vincent was
forced to climb could be taken as a
metaphor it symbolized the journey to
adulthood pressuring him to make his
tough life decisions
don't you agree I do agree
[Music]
with Vincent Vega not his ex-girlfriend
but the succubus to come back to him
that's [ __ ] weird she was shocked but
it looked like she was pretty pleased by
it
I gotta say he said some interesting
things while confessing his love that in
order to live a normal life you need
self-sacrifice and patience and if he's
gonna stick out he might as well live
freely
Vincent found an answer for himself
during the nightmares and maybe
Catherine accepted it because it reached
her heart as his true answer her
reaction might depend on how well she
can sense Vincent's feelings I think
that their future might just depend on
it now tell me what did all you players
out there think of this outcome he said
that he's willing to quit being human is
that okay
are you players who let him this far a
bit worried about him mmm-hmm
I just can't help myself let's take a
peek into the future and see what
happens next
alright alright
don't break the fourth wall please it's
[Music]
we got married
good morning you all right Iran Iran
have you been awake all this time
no kidding it's not like you let me get
any sleep
top of them on in kiddo good morning Wow
woman what in the [ __ ] don't mind me
just laying around of course I might you
why are you in my bed oh just ignore him
it's no big mystery Vincent he's here to
stop us sure a stalker huh yeah stalker
that's a cruel way to put it I mean I am
a god after all I'm working hard for the
sake of the world I hate this as much as
you do yeah don't worry just think of
him as decoration besides I love you
yeah I really love you
[Music]
yeah I love you too what the [ __ ] was
that ending
now that's your [ __ ] we're landing
are you kidding me
I want to replay the game right away
just to get another ending oh man oh man
oh man [ __ ] okay well that was a [ __ ]
awesome game I'm totally gonna replay it
came I doing a livestream of me we
playing it or something I don't know
probably not old takes it long but it
was so much fun to play I really really
enjoyed it it was kind of like watching
an anime and playing a game at the same
time I really got to give props to the
people who made this cuz it's such an
original concept and design of a game
and it's just cool when when people do
something different than another [ __ ]
Call of Duty I don't know so really
enjoyed it thought it was really cool I
think you bros enjoyed it as well it was
so much fun to hang out with you bros
it's been a while since we did a proper
series so I really thought this was
really awesome that you both came along
for this it reminds me of the good old
days [ __ ] love this game so glad I
found it and I I'm curious what else is
gonna come out or the people who made it
other than that I would just want to say
thank you both so much for watching it's
amazing as always that I can do this as
my job and just play [ __ ] games that
I really love for you bros it's really
cool to have an audience that like that
enjoys what I enjoy I don't have to be
forced to [ __ ] play Minecraft every
day or some function [ __ ]
that being said as always thank you for
watching and stay awesome bros